hey everybody i'm john cena and i play
peacemaker on a new show called you
guessed it peacemaker it's on hbo max
and you should watch it i'm with the
buzzfeed folks today and we are going to
read some thirst tweets not about john
cena the man about the myth the legend
peacemaker shall we
okay first tweet ratcatcher was the
heart of the suicide squad rick flag was
the soul peacemaker was the penis
hmm was it that short of a movie
i'll see peacemaker on the condition
that john cena shows up in his underwear
again give me that and you will have my
attention why am i going to lie i don't
mean to spoil anything for anybody but
if james gunn's involved chances are
peacemaker once again will be in his
beautiful tighty whities mary flag
peacemaker kill bloodsport sounds like
you're in for an interesting
relationship you're going to be wanted
for murder and one hell of a two and a
half minute ride if we can see john
cena's ass in peacemaker i will 100
watch well see you on hbo max john cena
as peacemaker makes my whole throb oh i
thought it was just one of us
why do these goofy ass pictures of john
cena in the peacemaker outfit turn me on
so much bro rail me we find a lot out
about ourselves every day and if
peacemakers asked had anything to do
with that here's to being a catalyst was
the almost naked peacemaker scene
necessary probably not did i still like
it obviously almost naked not sure what
show you watched
i hope the new dc comic peacemaker tv
show have john cena naked i want to see
that bubble butt wish granted see you on
hbo max and i'll keep doing my squats
for you okay peacemaker's junk looks
heavy in that underwear
movie magic and a piece of catering
fruit stuffed in a pair of tiny whities
i'm only watching peacemaker if i get to
see john cena's ham candle in a pair of
tidy whities again ham candle i might
have to borrow that my militaristic
daddy kink being heightened because of
john cena as peacemaker and what
i believe we've given
some forums a new fetish group to
explore congratulations and thank you
for your patronage when i saw a
peacemaker dancing in his underwear
again lord thanks for blessing me well
this is obviously a fan of interpretive
dance in the suicide squad we got to see
peacemaker walk in his tiny whities now
we see peacemaker dance in his tidy
whities and some people are still
entertained how that is i have no idea
but interesting i want to thank buzzfeed
for taking me on this peacemaker thirst
journey i want to thank you for being
brave enough to share your
innermost secrets behind the wall of
your avatar and keep them coming because
if you have more peacemaker thirsty
thoughts that means i may get to do this
again which means of course more
peacemaker on hbo max
you